I don't think it's any secret that if
one were to do any kind of science we're
going to be dealing with a lot of
numbers it doesn't matter whether you do
biology or chemistry or physics numbers
are involved and in many cases the
numbers are very large there are very
very large numbers very large numbers or
or they're very small very small numbers
very small numbers you could imagine
some very large numbers if I were to ask
you how many atoms are there in the
human body or how many even how many
cells are in the human body or the mass
of the earth in kilograms those are very
large numbers if I were to ask you if I
were to ask you the mass of an electron
that would be a very very small number
so any kind of science you're going to
be dealing with these and just as an
example let me show you one of the most
common numbers you're going to see and
especially chemistry is called
Avogadro's number
Avogadro's number and if I were to write
it in just the standard way of writing a
number it would literally be written as
do it a new color it would be six zero
two two and then another 2001 two three
four five six seven eight nine 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 and even if I
were to throw some commas in here it's
not going to really help the situation
to make it more readable
let me still throw some commas in here
it still this is still a huge number and
I don't even you know if I have to write
this on a piece of paper if I were to
publish some paper on you know using
Avogadro's number take me forever to
write this and even more it's hard to
tell if I forgot to write a 0 or if I
maybe wrote too many zeros so there's a
problem here is there a better way to
write this so is there a better way
better way to write this then to write
it all out like this to write literally
the six followed by the 23 digits or the
6 0 to 2 followed by the 2000 and to
answer that question and in case you're
curious Avogadro's number if you had 12
grams of carbon especially 12 grams of
carbon-12 this is
how many atoms you would have in that
and just so you know 12 grams is like a
fiftieth of a pound so that just gives
you an idea of how many atoms are are
laying around at any point in time this
is a huge number that's the point of
here isn't to teach you some chemistry
the point of here is to talk about an
easier way to write this and the easier
way to write this we call scientific
notation scientific scientific notation
and take my word for it although it
might be a little unnatural for you with
this video it really is an easier way to
write things like things like that so
let me before I show you how to do it
let me show you the underlying theory
behind scientific notation if I were to
tell you what what is 10 to the 0 power
we know that's equal to 1 what is 10 to
the 1 power less equal to 10
what's 10 squared that's 10 times 10
that's 100 what is 10 to the third 10 to
the third is 10 times 10 times 10 which
is equal to 1,000 I think you see a
general pattern here 10 to the 0 has no
zeros no zeros in it right 10 to the 1
has 1 0 10 to the 2 2 10 to the second
power let's see the tooth power 10 to
the second power has 2 zeroes finally 10
to the third has 3 zeros so want to beat
a dead horse here but I think you get
the idea 3 zeroes if I were to do if I
were to do 10 to the hundredth power 10
to the hundredth power what would that
look like
I don't feel like writing it all out
here but it would be 1 followed by you
could guess it 100 zeros so it'd just be
a bunch of zeros and if we were to count
up all of those zeros you would have 100
zeros right there and actually this
might be interesting just as an aside do
you you may or may not know what this
number is called this is called this is
called a Google Google in the early 90s
if someone said hey that's a you know
that's a Google you wouldn't have
thought of a search engine you would
have thought of the number 10 to the
100th power which is a
huge a huge number if you actually it's
it's more than the number of atoms or
the estimated number of atoms in the
known universe
in the known universe I mean you know
this is question of what else is there
out there but you know I was reading up
on this not too long ago and if I
remember correctly the known universe
has the order of 10 to the 79th - 10 to
the 81 atoms and this is of course rough
no one can really count this people are
just kind of estimating it or even
better guesstimating it but there's a
huge number but maybe even more
interesting to you is this number was
the motivation behind the naming a very
popular search engine Google Google
Google is essentially just a misspelling
of the word Google with the Oh L and I
don't know why they called it Google
maybe they got the domain name maybe
maybe they want to hold this much
information maybe that many bytes of
information or it's just a cool word
whatever it is maybe it was you know the
founders favorite number but it's a cool
thing to know but anyway I'm digressing
this is a Google it's just one with 100
zeros but I could equivalently have just
written that as 10 to 100 which is you
know clearly an easier way this is an
easier way to write this this is easier
in fact this is so hard to write that
didn't even take the trouble to write it
who have taken me forever this was just
2008 here 100 zeros I would have filled
up and I would I would have filled up
this green and you'd have found it
boring so I didn't even write it so
clearly this is easier to write and so
you might well how can we write this is
just good for powers of 10 right but how
can we write something that isn't a
direct power of 10 how can we use the
power of the simplicity how can we use
the power of the simplicity somehow and
to do that you just need to make the
realization this number this number we
could write it as so this has how many
digits in it has 1 2 3 and then 2003
digits after the 6 right 23 digits after
the 6 so what happens if I have if I use
this if I try to get close to it with
the power of 10
so what if I were to say 10 to the 23
dude in this magenta 10 to the 23rd
power that's equal to what that equals 1
with 23 zeros the 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23
you get the idea that's 10 to the 23rd
now can we somehow write this guy is
some multiple of this guy what we can
because if we multiply this guy by 6 so
what is 6 if we multiply 6 times 10 to
the 23rd what do we get well we're just
going to have a 6 with 23 zeroes we're
going to have a 6 and then you're going
to have 2300 that you're gonna have 2306
times this you don't have to multiply it
down to 6 times this one you get a 6 and
all the six times the zeros will all be
0 so we'll have 6 followed by 23 zeros
so that's pretty useful but still we're
not getting quite to this number I mean
this had some this had some twos in
there so how can you do it a little bit
better
well what if we wrote it as a decimal
this number this number right here is
identical to this number as if these
tools were zeros but if we have we want
to put those twos there what can we do
we could put some decimals here we could
say that this is the same thing as 6.022
times 10 to the 23rd and now this number
is identical to this number but it's a
much easier way to write it and you
could verify it if you like it'll take
you a long time maybe we should do it
with a smaller number first if you
multiply 6.022 times 10 to the 23rd and
you write it all out you will get this
number right there you will get
Avogadro's number of Oh God rose
Avogadro x' number and although this is
complicated or it looks a little bit
unintuitive to you at first you know
this was just a number written out this
has a multiplication and then a 10 to a
power you might say hey that's not so
simple but it really is because you
immediately know how many zeros there
are and it's obviously a much shorter
way to write this number let's do a
couple of more this was I started with
Avogadro's number because it really
shows you the need
for a scientific notation so you don't
have to write things like that over and
over again so let's do a couple of other
numbers we'll just write them in
scientific notation
so let's say I have the number let's say
I have the number seven thousand three
hundred and forty five and I wanted to
write it a scientific notation so the I
guess the best way to think about it is
it's seven thousand three hundred and
forty five so how can I represent kind
of a thousand well I wrote it over here
ten to the third is a thousand so we
know that 10 to the third is equal to
one thousand so that's essentially the
largest power of 10 that I can fit into
this this is seven thousand so if this
is seven thousands and then it's point
three thousands then it's point O four
thousands I don't know if that helps you
we can write this as seven point three
four five times 10 to the third because
it's going to be seven thousand plus
point three thousands what's point three
times a thousand point three times 1000
is three hundred what's 0.04 times a
thousand that's 40 what's 0.005 times a
thousand that's a five so seven point
three four five times a thousand is
equal to seven thousand three hundred
and forty-five let me multiply it out
just to make it clear so if I took seven
point three four five times one thousand
the way I do it is I ignore the zeros I
says essentially multiply one times that
guy up there so I get seven three four
five then I had three zeros here so I
put those on the end and then I have
three decimal places one two three so
one two three put the decimal right
there
and there you have it seven point three
four five times 1000 is indeed seven
thousand three hundred and forty five
let's do a couple of them let's say we
wanted to write the number six in
scientific notation obviously there's no
need to write in scientific notation but
how would you do it well what's the
largest power of ten that fits into six
well the largest power of ten that fits
into six is just one so we could write
it as something times 10 to the zero
this is just 1 right that's just one so
six is what times one what's just 6 so 6
is equal to 6
times 10 to the zero you wouldn't
actually have to write it this way this
is much simpler but it shows you that
you really can express any number in
scientific notation now what if we
wanted to represent something like this
I started off the video saying in
science you deal with very large and
very small numbers so let's say you had
the number I'll do it in this color
let's see the number one and you have
one two three four and then let's say
five zeroes and then you have followed
by a seven once again this is not an
easy number to deal with but how can we
deal with it as a power of 10 as a power
of 10 so what's the largest power of 10
that fits into this number that this
number is divisible by so let's think
about it ever all the powers of 10 we
did before we're going to positive or
going to well yeah positive powers of 10
we could also do negative powers of 10
we know the 10 to the 0 is 1 let's start
there 10 to the minus 1 is equal to 1
over 10 which is equal to 0.1 we switch
colors I'll do pink 10 to the minus 2 is
equal to 1 over 10 squared which is
equal to 1 over 100 which is equal to
0.01 and you I think you get the idea
that they well let me just do one more
so that you can get the idea 10 to the
minus 3 10 to the minus 3 is equal to 1
over 10 to the third which is equal to 1
over 1000 which is equal to point zero
zero one so the general pattern here is
10 to the whatever negative power is
however many places you're going to have
behind the decimal point so here it's
not the number of zeros in here is 10 to
the minus 3 you only have two zeros we
have three places behind the decimal
point
so what is the largest power of 10 that
it goes into this well how many decimal
places behind the decimal point do I
have I have one two three four five six
so ten to the minus six is going to be
equal to point and we're going to have
six places behind the decimal point and
the last point is going to be or the
last place is going to be one so you're
gonna have five zeros
and a-one that's ten to the minus six
now this number right here is seven
times this number right if we multiply
this times 7 times 7 we get 7 times 1
and then we have one two three four five
six numbers behind the decimal point so
one two three four five six so this
number times seven is clearly equal to
the number that we started off with so
we can rewrite this number we can
rewrite we can instead of writing this
number every time we can write it as
being equal to this number or we could
write it as seven this is equal to seven
times this number but this number is no
better than that number but this number
is the same thing is ten to the minus
six seven times ten to the minus six so
now you can imagine no numbers like
imagine the number I what if what if we
had a seven let me think of it this way
what if we had a seven say we had a
seven three over there so what would we
do well we'd want to go to the first
digit right here because this is kind of
the the largest power of 10 that can be
they could go into this thing right here
so if we wanted to represent that thing
let me write let me do another decimal
that's like that one so let's say I did
one point zero zero zero zero five one
six and I wanted to represent this in
scientific notation I'd go to the first
non digit zero the first non-zero digit
not nun not non digit zero which is
there I'm like okay what's the largest
power of 10 that'll fit into that so
I'll go one two three four five so it's
going to be equal to five point one six
so I take five there and then everything
else is going to be the behind the
decimal point times 10 so this is going
to be the largest power of 10 that fits
into this first nonzero number so it's
one two three four five so 10 to the
minus 5 power let me do another example
so I have the point I wanted to make is
you just go to the first you go to the
first if you're starting at the left the
first nonzero number that's what you get
your power from that's where I got my 10
to the minus 5 because I kind of 1 2 3 4
5 you got to count that number just like
we did over here and then everything
else will be bhai
the decimal let me do another example
let's say at Point and my wife always
points out that I have to write a zero
in front of my decimal points because
she's a doctor and if people don't see
the decimal point someone might overdose
on some medication so let's write it her
way
zero point zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero eight one nine two
clearly this is a super cumbersome
number right and you know you might
forget about as your add too many zeros
which could be costly if you're doing
some important scientific research or
maybe doing well you would prescribe
medicine at this small dose or maybe you
would I know I don't want to get into
that but how would I write this in
scientific notation so I start off with
the first nonzero number if I'm starting
from the left so it's going to be eight
point one nine two I just put a decimal
and write point one nine two x times 10
to the what I just count times ten to
the one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten I have to include that
number ten to the minus ten and I think
you'll find it reasonably satisfactory
that this number is easier to write than
that number over there now and this is
another powerful thing about scientific
notation let's say I have these two
numbers and I want to multiply them
let's say I want to multiply the number
point zero zero five times the number
times the number point
0:08 this is actually a fairly
straightforward one to to do but
sometimes it can get quite cumbersome
especially if you're dealing with twenty
or thirty zeros on either sides of the
decimal point zero here to make my wife
happy but when you're doing in
scientific notation will actually
simplify it this guy can be rewritten as
five times ten to the what I have one
two three spaces behind the decimal 10
to the third and then this is eight so
this is times 8 times 10 to the sorry
this is five times 10 to the minus 3
it's very important 5 times 10 to the
three would have been five thousand be
very careful lying about that now what
does this guy equal to this is one two
three four places behind the decimal so
it's 8 times 10 to the minus
or so for multiplying numbers so this is
if we're multiplying these two things
this is the same thing as 5 times 10 to
the minus 3 times 8 times 10 to the
minus 4 there's nothing special about
the scientific notation it literally
means what it's saying so for
multiplying you could write it out like
this and multiplication order doesn't
matter so I can rewrite this as 5 times
8 times 10 to the minus 3 times 10 to
the minus 4 and then what is 5 times 8 5
times 8 we know is 40 so it's 40 times
10 to the minus 3 times 10 to the minus
4 and if you know your exponent rules
you know that when you multiply two
numbers that have the same base you can
just add their exponents so you just add
the minus 3 and the minus 4 so it
becomes it's equal to 40 times 10 to the
minus 7 let's do another example let's
say we were to multiply Avogadro's
number so we know that 6.022 times 10 to
the 23rd let's say we were multiply that
times some really small number so times
say let's say it's 7 point 2 3 times 10
to the minus 22 so this is some really
small number you're going to have a
decimal and then you're gonna have 21
zeros then you're gonna have a 7 and
then 2 and a 3 so this is some really
small number but the multiplication when
you do it in scientific notation is
actually fairly straightforward this is
going to be equal to six point oh let me
write it properly 6.022
times 10 to the 23rd times 7 point 2 3
times 10 to the minus 22 we can change
the order so it's equal to six point oh
two two times seven point two three
that's that part so you can view it as
these first parts of our scientific
notation x times 10 to the 23rd times 10
to the minus 22 and now this this is you
know you're gonna have to do some little
decimal multiplication right here it's
going to be some number forty something
I think but I don't I can't do this one
in my head but this part is pretty easy
to calculate
I'll just leave this as the way it is
but this part right here is easy this
will be times 10 to the 23rd times 10 to
the minus 23 you just add exponents you
get times 10 to the first power or times
10 and then this number whatever it's
going to equal I'll just leave it out
here since I don't have a calculator
7.23 let's see what it'll be 7.2 let's
see 0.2 times it's like 1/5 it'll be
like 41 something so this is
approximately approximately 41 times 10
to the 1 or another way it's
approximately it's a little bits going
to be 410 something and to get the to
get it right you just have to actually
perform this multiplication so hopefully
you see that scientific notation is one
really useful for super large and super
small numbers and that not only is it's
more useful to kind of understand the
numbers and to write the numbers but it
also simplifies operating on the numbers